This is a clip from my upcoming interview
with Waterstones about the book,
The Trading Game
that's coming out March the fifth.
If you preorder from Waterstones
using the code in the description,
then you can get 20% off.
So that will be valid for all preorders.
So up to March 4th.
Hope you enjoy the interview.
You actually, you describe very well
the sort of unhappiness
actually that comes from being given that
kind of wealth, living the kind of life
you were living, going to different parts
of the world as part of your job.
But really none of that actually
making you happy or filling the void.
You know, it's a funny one.
This didn’t
get into the book, actually, but
suddenly it's coming back to me.
One conversation I had with the girl
who I was dating at the time,
and I got this first big bonus,
and it's one of the first few moments
when I sort of actually thought about
why does this money not make me happy?
And I think when you’re...
I don't want to glamorise
poverty at all, but when you're young
and you've got nothing,
everything's like a positive bet,
because you got nothing to lose.
And then suddenly you get given this money
and it's like, I've never had anything.
You know, when I was a kid,
I lived in a tiny little bedroom
with my brother in a bunk bed,
and everything I owned was in a random
shelf.
Like a chest of drawers that had been
taken up, just under the bed.
Everything I owned was in that draw.
And then suddenly someone gives you
half a million pounds.
You know, I didn't have my own, you know,
I'd never owned anything.
I was scared of shops.
I didn't know how shops worked.
I'd never been in a shop.
And then
suddenly you get half a million pounds.
You know what?
What do you do?
And then there's a scene in the book where
they say, buy something for your dad.
And I'm like,
I don't even know what that means,
you know, because, like,
I've never bought anything for anyone.
They’re like, what does your Dad like?
I dunno he likes football,
buy him sky sports then.
But what they didn't know was before
I was working at the bank,
I used to go with my dad to Leyton Orient
every week.
You know, it was £23 a year for season
ticket for kids.
And we used to sit next to each other
and watch the game with Harry Samby who's
also a character in the book.
But when I was working at the bank,
I didn't have time for that anymore.
I was so busy.
So then they think that
this money is like a path for me
to bring happiness to my family.
They don't realise that actually it’s
taking me away from my family.
And then I would wake up on Saturdays
and I'd see my dad watching the midday
kick off on Sky Sports.
And it made me so unhappy.
And it was just this.
But it's another one of those things
that you just kind of compartmentalise
and you just, you hide away
the things that you losing and you focus
on the things that you winning.
But, you know, I think the book, it
captures it very well, the sort of descent
into unhappiness and also perhaps
a sort of madness that came.
So what do you do?
I think there's this,
but it's not just me.
Even though I come from a poor background,
I think there's this,
that trading floor is a room
full of people who to some degree
have traded their happiness for money
and are trying to trade it back.
Yeah. And that's why you see them.
They go and they buy, you know,
amazing new bike and they never ride it.
They buy a whole new set of skis.
They’re trying to buy back the happiness
and the youth that they've traded away.
And it's a big thing
I want to get across in the book is
the sadness of this space, you know.
That is a room full of very unhappy men
and very wealthy, unhappy men.
And what does that mean?
That we've constructed our society
in that way?
There are some, as I said earlier,
fascinating characters in the book
that you worked with.
And I wonder
if we could talk about a couple of them.
The first of them
is the man who sort of frames the book
because he's there at the beginning
and he's there right at the end as well,
which is Caleb,
could you tell us a little bit
about about Caleb
and why he's such an incredible character?
Yes, I mean, Caleb was kind of...
Caleb was the guy who ran the
trading game competition and
very smooth, charming, charismatic man.
He was the youngest ever
managing director at Citibank,
which is like a really big deal.
And he sort of comes in, he’s
this massive guy, larger than life.
And he recognised very quickly, Gary’s
like really, really smart.
Let's get this guy in.
And of course, you know, I'm
just like a little kid, basically.
And I see this guy
like he's the super rich trader.
Like he's the guy.
I want to be like this guy.
And then he hires me, he brings me in, and
then very suddenly he leaves
and he sort of, he leaves.
Because he's, in a sense,
he's like, lived the dream.
And another big theme of the book is,
do you leave? Can you leave?
Do people leave? And this guy does it.
And then that sort of,
you know, as it develops,
it turns out that this departure
was not as simple as it seems.
And perhaps he had appeared to be able
to leave, but he wasn't able to leave.
And they sort of, you know,
I don't wanna give too much away.
But it raises questions essentially about
appearances.
This guy appeared so seductive
and so complete,
and yet he was unable to leave
despite being super rich.
And this mirrors, of course,
my own journey, which my own
beginning of questioning,
should you leave.
And of course, that raises
bigger questions about really,
I think, the effect of money and the
effects of greed and the effects of power
on the individual. And
I think we all face these questions
on some level, you know,
we all pursue money
and have questions about, you know,
should I work harder or should I spend
more time with my family? But
he was my first ever boss and he was also
my final boss.
He was not my boss the whole time.
And our relationship went on a journey,
let's say, I don't want to give
too much away, but, you know,
readers can experience what I experienced.
Yeah.
Because there is something almost mafia
like in the sort of,
the threat of you
not basically being able to as you say,
are you going to get paid is the question
you keep asking the book.
Because if you leave,
if you try to leave the job,
you're your bonus
for those who don't understand
is not simply a big check that you get
and that's it.
It's paid
incrementally over a period of time.
So that means if you say
I'm leaving the job, goodbye bonus.
Yeah.
So it's like, how do you get,
how do you actually get the money
that you're supposed to get?
Yeah, I wanted to,
one thing
I really wanted to do with this book.
I think, like I was quite lucky.
Like from a literary
perspective, you've got a nice opportunity
because I grew up in East London,
not far from these skyscrapers,
and then I work in this space,
and these two spaces
physically are not that far apart.
from one another, but
they're completely different worlds right.
And so you want to play with like the,
the contrast we go in, you know,
we talk about waking up like
and having a shower
with this little hand hose
from Argos that you plug into the taps
and then like going
into these massive skyscrapers
and then working with these millionaires
and then going home to your, like,
crowded house and this kind of thing. But
you know,
the opening scene of the book
is basically me being threatened
by this character Caleb and it's
very, it's very mafia esque, you know,
and when I was a kid,
I come from a very poor background.
I grew up in a pretty rough area.
I was expelled from school
for selling drugs.
You know,
I wouldn't say
I was a drug dealer, ever a criminal,
but you know, these elements existed
around me in the street I grew up,
you know.
There were drug dealers
and there were criminals.
I grew up with these people.
And, you know, I did the right thing.
I studied hard.
I got a good job.
And you kind of think that you're
you're going that way.
You're choosing another path. And then
I quickly became very senior at Citibank
and then you suddenly see,
like, when you’re doing what they want
you to do, everything's fine.
As soon as you start veering, suddenly,
these guys are acting just like the same
way that drug dealers on the street act.
Right.
And what I wanted to do was,
you know, collapse
that physical space and say, listen,
these people may look very different
and they may, they may run your life
and they may have all the power.
But once you dig a bit
beneath the surface, you know,
are they any better than us?
Are they any, you know, and,
you know, my experience
of those two spaces was, you know,
they're basically the same, you know,
and I think that is an empowering message,
you know,
to people from both sides of the coin,
which is like, you know,
if you come from a poor background, don’t
think these people are better than you
because they're not.
And if you come from a rich background,
don't think you're
better than those people
because that can get you in trouble.
You know,
and I think that's very, very relevant in
this society
we live in of increasing inequality.
You know, people who know the work
I do outside of this book will know
this is something I'm very passionate
about, I think it's a massive problem.
One of the fascinating characters
in the book, is Billy.
He's quite an enigma.
But tell me a little bit about him
and why he was so important.
So Billy was the only trader on my desk
who didn't go to university.
And when I started working in 2008,
he was already in his mid-to-late 40s.
He's from Liverpool, he's a Scouser.
He had a strong Scouse accent and he came
from a very working class background.
He started working as a teenager
on the cash desk at Halifax
and he's managed to work his way up
over the course of like 30 years
to being senior trader at Citibank. And
when I
turn up, he's had a rough couple of years.
He's not done very well and he basically
hates everyone on the trading floor.
He thinks that they’re really posh,
and people are like who's this guy?
Who's this dickhead basically,
because he's not making any money.
But I obviously, because I see he's
from a sort of similar background to me.
I think like,
this is a guy I want to make friends with.
And there's one scene really early
in the book when some guy's on another
desk, he keep playing music,
and he keeps saying “turn the music down.”
They keep turning it back
on, and eventually he just pulls
the wires of the speakers
through the desk and just snips them.
And then the guys come “What,
what’s going on!?”
And then I was like,
this is the guy I wanna hang out with.
But suddenly in the 2008
crisis, this guy just makes an absolute
unbelievable fortune.
And it turns out he's been sitting there
just betting that the world's
going to blow up for years.
And we formed a very close bond
and he sort of takes me under his wing and
he kind of becomes,
I guess, a bit of a spiritual guru
to me in a way, and also a trading guy,
because he's a very, very good trader.
And after I have my first big loss,
which is into my second year as a trader,
I instinctively
went back to the textbooks.
I start bringing my textbooks
into the office and I'm sitting next
to Billy by this point,
I'm like Billy's junior, and
I'm reading the textbooks every day.
After like the second or third day,
Billy just can't take it anymore.
Just slaps the textbooks out of my hand
straight into the bin.
He’s like “What the fuck are you doing?
You're not a kid anymore.
You're not going to find out the key
to the world in those textbooks.
If you want to know
what's happening in the world,
if you wanna know
what's happening in the economy,
go home and ask your mum
what's happening in her economy.
Ask your friends, ask friend’s mums.
Walk down the high street
and look at what's happening.
The shops are closing down, you know,
look at the homeless people.
Is there more or less of them?
You know, look at what’s
being advertised on the tube.
And he basically says to me, you know,
if you want to understand the economy,
the time comes, you have to go out
and look at the fucking economy.
You can't just read about it in books.
And that was a big moment for me
where it sort of, and in a sense is
sort of the catalyst for everything
that's happened since,
which is my willingness to sort of
step out of the theory and into the world
and that’s what propels me into becoming
the very successful trader I became.
Yeah, because you had a good sense,
as you say, of what was actually happening
so that after that crash
that you mentioned, where Billy makes
a lot of money, everyone's
expecting for things to return to normal.
Yeah.
But your sense told you it's not.
It's not going to return to normal. It's
broken.
Interest rates are going to stay low.
Everything's going to stay down here.
And that was how you made your millions,
you know, as a trader,
because you kept betting against
what everybody else was expecting.
We were talking about this.
If the moral deviousness is something like
Wolf of Wall Street, obviously
looking back now, making huge
amounts of money when you're doing it.
But wealth inequality, as you say,
that's what you could see.
How did it feel writing about that?
And sort of now, obviously, you’re
an activist in terms of economics,
but how does it sort of square with you
sort of having made that money
basically
off the back of a broken economy?
Yeah, There's this one scene in the book
which I think is quite good to say myself,
which is where I kind of have this penny
drop moment.
I finally realised, this is it.
This is what's going to happen,
which is you know,
I start to realise like, it's 2011, which
is the year of the sovereign debt crisis.
So like all of the big governments in
Europe basically collapsed financially and
I start to see before this has happened,
like these governments
are going to go bankrupt
and I start to see the similarity
between them
and my friends, and my friends families
start losing their houses,
going into debt.
And I start thinking, okay, well,
almost all the ordinary people
are losing their assets,
going into debt, governments are losing
their assets, are going into debt.
Where's it going?
And then, you know,
I'm surrounded by these millionaires.
Okay, what we have here
is, you know, there's a shift of power.
There's a shift of ownership,
there's a shift of wealth.
It's being drained out of the middle
class, out of governments, into the rich.
What the rich going to do with that?
They're going to buy more assets,
which means it's going to accelerate,
which means that the middle class
will become completely impoverished.
There'll be an explosion in poverty
in this country.
Governments will be bankrupted.
It's going to
you know, it's going to cause
basically the collapse of Western society.
And then it's, there's this penny drop,
it’s like, I know what I’ve got to do.
I've got to buy green Eurodollars.
You look back and you're like, you know,
here is a very talented young kid.
He's obviously smart.
He's figured out a really important thing
and his instinct is: monetise.
And that is the person
that I was trained to be.
That was my job.
You know what I mean? So it's sort of,
I think it's,
when I look back
I don't think about it morally.
I'm you know, I'm
a mathematician in my heart.
I think, listen,
this is the society we've built.
You know,
there are people whose job it is to manage
our economy
and they get paid 50 grand a year.
And there's people
whose job it is to bet on our economy,
and they get paid £2 million a year.
Right.
If that is how you can structure economy,
what do you think is going to happen?
You know,
and I've walked away now from that money
and now I sort of try to prevent,
you know, economic collapse.
I’m not doing the best job of it
so far. But I'm still going for it.
You know, I'm not out here trying to be
Mahatma Gandhi.
I'm not a moral philosopher.
What I wanted to do with this book,
I didn't want to make any moral judgments.
You know, it's a bit like,
have you read Candide by Voltaire?
I think the most powerful way
to show people how broken our system is
not for me to tell them it's broken.
It's for me to take them with me,
take them to the places I've been,
take them to the top of the mountain
and show them the tsunami that's coming,
you know,
and people can make their own judgments
about whether it's right,
whether it's wrong.
People who are interested
can go and look at the work that I do now.
They can look at my YouTube channel
and I think it's pretty clear
where I stand on it.
But, you know, I was a young kid.
My job was to bet on the economy.
And that's what I did.
And it's, you know, it's not just me,
you know, the best paid
10,000 economists in the world.
All traders, all traders,
they don't work for your governments. So
that's the way the world is I'm afraid.
I didn't make it that way.